[Musik]
warten auf das große ereignis seit
monaten steht der termin dafür fest
familie freunde kollegen alle sind
heutige konno fiebern dem großen
ereignis entgegen der geburt eines
kindes
[Musik]
die ersten fotos aus dem kreißsaal
mutter und kind geht es gut
[Musik]
alltägliche szenen auf der
geburtsstation einer privatklinik in rio
de janeiro 1000 kinder kommen hier jeden
monat zur welt
85 prozent von ihnen per kaiserschnitt
[Musik]
der stolze vater eine action cam noch
auf dem kopf darauf gespeichert
unwiederbringliche eindrücke
[Musik]
nirgendwo sonst machen ärzte mehr
kaiserschnitte als in brasilien aber
auch in anderen ländern steigt die zahl
rasant die geburtshilfe steht an einem
scheideweg
[Musik]
[Applaus]
eigentlich
[Musik]
der weltweite trend zum kaiserschnitt
der essex pharma stellt den sinn der
natürlichen geburt in frage wie nie
zuvor und schwangere vor eine große
entscheidung ich stolz dass ich es
geschafft hat und das ist natürlich
schmerzhaft
ich habe schon zum kaiserschnitt
tendiert aber eigentlich gab es nichts
was mich an einer normalen geburt
gehindert hätte hätte mich ein arzt mir
in dieser richtung beraten hätte ich
mich wahrscheinlich für die normale
geburt entschieden
frauen zwischen angst und verunsicherung
die medizin ist geprägt von ökonomischen
überlegungen die gesellschaft fordert
immer mehr sicherheit in diesem
spannungsfeld zweifeln selbst mediziner
an der natürlichen geburt diese
unannehmlichkeiten sind nicht nötig der
schmerz der ganze stress die hektik das
muss man nur mitmachen wenn man es
unbedingt will kliniken bieten neue
arten des kaiserschnitts an der
natürlichen geburt zu ähnlich wie
möglich was aber bedeutet das für die
frauen
geburt ist eine existenziell bedeutsame
situation in die die frau geworfen ist
und die mit fürsorge die mit begegnungs
arbeit aufgefangen werden könnte und
statt dessen agieren wir mit technik nun
zeigen neue forschungen dass der
kaiserschnitt möglicherweise auch
ursache für spätere erkrankungen sein
könnte
[Musik]
es gab sicher an den generationen
mediziner die klar gesagt hat der
kaiserschnitt ist das sicherste fürs
kind deswegen machen wir das und jahre
später sehen wir es ist vielleicht doch
nicht das sicherste innerhalb von
wenigen jahrzehnten hat sich die
kaiserschnittrate in vielen
industrienationen mehr als verdoppelt
ganz anders die situation in afrika
hier sterben mütter und kinder noch weil
kein kaiserschnitt möglich ist
in europa sind die zahlen sehr
unterschiedlich während in der schweiz
und in deutschland über 30 prozent der
schwangeren per schnitt entbinden sind
es in frankreich nur 21 prozent
unbestritten ist der kaiserschnitt kann
leben retten
er hat die mütter und
kindersterblichkeit in den letzten
jahrzehnten auf ein minimum gesenkt aber
wann ist eine sektion wirklich nötig
welche folgen hat sie für mutter und
kind
in der schweiz hat sich die anzahl der
schnitt entbindungen in den letzten 30
jahren verdoppelt
auch sonja boots glaubt der lange zeit
das für sie nichts anderes in frage käme
die 38 jährige ist zum zweiten mal
schwanger
nach der ersten komplizierten geburt
machte er der arzt keine hoffnungen noch
einmal natürlich gebären zu können nun
beim zweiten kind drohte eine frühgeburt
sonja burzler deshalb bereits zwei
monate im spital
dort wendete sich das blatt plötzlich
die ärzte schlossen eine natürliche
geburt nicht mehr aus
[Musik]
wir stimmen bin ich völlig tabuisiert
sind also vorstellt wie verrückt weil
ich einfach kann ja was jetzt was ich
jetzt auch an normal gebären kann ihnen
die sachen jetzt meine drei jahre lang
hat man sich für mich ist ausgestrichen
sie kann mir keine gedanken über die
normale geburt gemacht um nach dem ist
und so lange mit einem spital kabine hat
man mir ich hab mich dass ich danke mir
versuche ich zuerst eher normal gebucht
als spieler im event ihre chance gibt
und irgendwann hat sich dass es auch
wirklich in ihm gedanke kommen und ich
hoffe da fange black und wieder
auffangen lassen und wieder fangen mit
hebammen im unispital reden und hat dann
doch nicht entschieden doch normal
gebucht war ich schon zum probieren und
haben das mit erzählt dass der moment wo
sich heute das ist der normale gebotenen
fahrer kennen das ist das wird man mit
überlegen bin ich schoss pittsburgh und
unnötiges risiko vorhanden wird sie für
das letzte mal bin ich fix und zürichsee
und achse dass das einfach gar nicht
komisch in dem moment der kopf des
kindes passte nicht durch das becken
eine sogenannte absolute indikation die
sectio ist dann unumgänglich
im gegensatz dazu stehen relative
indikationen zum beispiel bei einer
steißlage des babys bei zwillingen oder
einem vorherigen kaiserschnitt hier
müssen ärzte und schwangere ab werden
[Musik]
das paar hat lange überlegt wie ihr
zweites kind zur welt kommen soll sich
auch im freundeskreis umgehört und dabei
festgestellt dass es oft die männer sind
die einen kaiserschnitt befürworten
setzen partner kommt dass es existierte
und kontrollverluste im moment also
quasi die partnerinstitutionen sich
wahrscheinlich niemals vorher oder
nachher immer wieder wird sie und ich
denke dass das niemand respekt bedeutet
weltraum muss ich eine gala die ganze
hülle verliere und das team von trainer
menschen wo vor ort sind und teilweise
augen hat und heute morgen ist es
erschreckend märkten frau hat schmerzen
und leipzig gold und kann ich mache und
ich denke die meisten wesentlich
sonja bolz möchte dennoch lieber
natürlich gebären eine letzte
untersuchung im zürcher unispital soll
zeigen ob sich ihr wunsch erfüllt ein
wunsch den weltweit nicht mehr alle
ärztinnen und ärzte unterstützen und der
vielerorts auch unter frauen abnimmt
[Musik]
wachsender wohlstand und körperkult
prägen brasilien das land ist nicht nur
weltweit spitzenreiter bei schönheits op
sondern auch beim kaiserschnitt
er hat die natürliche geburt bereits
überholt wer es sich leisten kann meidet
das öffentliche gesundheitssystem
barbara griesbach und ja man robertos in
privat versichert sie dürfen daher einen
arzt wählen der sie zehn monate lang bis
zur geburt begleitet ein luxus
einerseits
der besuch beim ersten arzt hat mich
total ernüchtert ich war so verzaubert
von meiner schwangerschaft für mich war
das so etwas magisches
dann kommt man zum arzt und er fängt an
über preise zu reden
er erklärt einem das alles was mit dem
kaiserschnitt zu tun hat viel günstiger
ist als die normale geburt denn da
müsste er einem jahr die ganze zeit zur
verfügung stehen
barbara hätte für die normale geburt
5000 franken zusätzlich zahlen sollen
gemeinsam mit ihrer mutter entschied sie
sich für die op ohne aufpreis
gerade jetzt braucht das studenten paar
geld für andere dinge
das ist genau das geld das man braucht
um möbel zu kaufen
kleidung und all diese sachen das
finanziell aber also siehe sie
entscheidend für uns die 22-jährige
versuchte es noch mit einer anderen
ärztin
doch auch sie riet zur 6
der trend zum kaiserschnitt nahm in
brasilien bereits in den 1960 er jahren
seinen lauf frauen die es sich leisten
konnten ließen sich bei der op
gleichzeitig sterilisieren ungewollt
immer wieder schwanger zu werden war das
los der armen
so fragten sich irgendwann all die
schwangeren die in öffentlichen
krankenhäusern ihre kinder kriegen
mussten warum habe ich eigentlich kein
recht auf einen kaiserschnitt
das muss doch etwas gutes sein wenn all
die reichen frauen das machen lassen
die wissenschaftlerin silvana granada
hat im auftrag der regierung mit ihrem
team 24.000 frauen zum thema geburt
befragt und dabei erstaunliches
festgestellt
am anfang der schwangerschaft möchten
die meisten brasilianerinnen ihr kind
auf natürliche weise bekommen
veränderung geschieht während der
schwangerschaft begleitung ärzte wegen
den frauen ein dass sie nicht gebären
können sie sagen dass es probleme gibt
bei der natürlichen geburt als der
kaiserschnitt sicherer sei obwohl sie
wissen dass das nicht wahr ist die
studie sorgt er für einen aufschrei
politiker schalteten sich ein
inzwischen werben aufklärungskampagnen
für die natürliche geburt doch der
kaiserschnitt ist längst fester
bestandteil der brasilianischen geburts
kultur ja die frauen werden zum
kaiserschnitt getrennt aber gleichzeitig
denken sie auch sie hatte keine
schmerzen haben werde mich nicht
anstrengen müssen
ich kann mir das datum ausbilden und
dazu die familie und freunde einlagen
das ist für brasilianer sehr wichtig der
kaiserschnitt als happening einst sollte
er das leben von mutter und kind retten
und wurde nur im notfall durchgeführt
heute ist die sektion die häufigste
operation der welt sie dauert nur noch
knapp 20 minuten
die vollnarkose wird häufig durch eine
rückenmark spritze eine sogenannte pda
ersetzt die den bauch beträgt schon
während der op gibt man der mutter
antibiotika um infektionen vorzubeugen
[Musik]
die gucken
das lieblings drehen
[Musik]
lange zeit glaubten medizinerinnen und
mediziner
der kaiserschnitt stelle zwar für die
frau ein erhöhtes risiko dar sei aber
das sicherste für das kind neue studien
zum mikro biom der gesamtheit aller
unserer keime lassen daran zweifeln
kaiserschnitt kinder entwickeln
möglicherweise durch das stabile umfeld
des operationssaals eine veränderte
immunabwehr anders als babys die den
geburtskanal der mutter passieren und
von der ersten sekunde an lernen mit
keimen umzugehen
ein kaiserschnitt bedeutet aber auch für
das baby ein erhöhtes risiko das sind
neue daten die sind vor allen dingen von
kinder ärzten weltweit erhoben worden
aber wir müssen die ernst nehmen wir
können nicht einfach dann sagen das
scheint mir aber doch jetzt für mich
ganz persönlich kein so großes risiko zu
sein
da muss die antwort sein sie können
selbst ihre informierte entscheidung
treffen aber ich kann ihnen nicht
vorenthalten dass die daten sicher sind
so zeigen die studien dass kaiserschnitt
kinder möglicherweise anfälliger für
allergien asthma darm erkrankungen oder
diabetes sind
[Musik]
im universitätsspital zürich
unterstützen mediziner schwangere daher
darin ihr kind auf natürliche weise zu
bekommen
ein grund warum sich das ehepaar boots
für dieses krankenhaus entschieden hat
vor allem aber ist ihnen wichtig dass
auch für einen eventuellen notfall alles
bereitsteht
das gibt auch der betreuenden ärzte in
naila sultan bayer einen größeren
handlungsspielraum
also wenn dir einer notfallsituation
haben und einer spontangeburt zum
beispiel dass es zu einer möglichen
komplikationen kommt oder zu einem
totalen komplikationen haben wir den
notfallknopf den eben nur größere
zentren eigentlich haben
und da ist sie in weniger als zehn
minuten ist das kind auf der welt sobald
man den knopf auslöst stehen alle parat
es ist der operationssaal es bei uns
auch direkt auf der gewerbe teilung auf
dem gleichen niveau sozusagen
und dann ist in weniger als zehn minuten
das kind entbunden
ganz anders trug sich vor etwa 500
jahren der erste erfolgreiche
kaiserschnitt zu im kanton thurgau lebte
der schweine castor jakob nova seine
frau lag seit tagen in den wehen
doch das kind kam und kann nicht der
schwangeren drohte ein qualvoller tod
das wollte er man nicht hinnehmen und
entschloss sich selbst hand anzulegen
jakob nufer schmidt seiner frau den
bauch auf holte eigenhändig das kind
heraus und vernähte die wunde mit nadel
und zwirn
seine frau soll danach problemlos noch
sechs weitere kinder bekommen haben
doch wahrscheinlich war dies alles nur
ein glücklicher zufall denn erst drei
jahrhunderte später begann ein neues
zeitalter in der geburtsmedizin
ferdinand adolph gera ein arzt aus
heidelberg nähte zum ersten mal nicht
nur den bauch der frauen sondern auch
ihre gebärmutter zu
damit sank sofort das infektionsrisiko
die müttersterblichkeit nahm drastisch
ab noch vier wochen bis zum errechneten
geburtstermin
mittlerweile hat sich auch michael boots
mit dem gedanken einer natürlichen
geburt angefreundet
das paar kennt die risiken sieht dennoch
eher die vorteile es weiß dass ihr baby
neben den nützlichen keimen auch noch
einen wertvollen hormoncocktail
mitbekommen wird adrenalin und cortisol
für die reife der lungen sowie jede
menge oxytocin das sogenannte
liebeshormon es sorgt sofort nach der
geburt für eine optimale mutter kind
bindung
[Musik]
seitlich ein bisschen spüren sie wie es
bewegt das kind die lungen sind reif vom
kind jetzt hat sich ein gutes gewicht
ich gehe es gleich noch ein aber sieht
sieht alles gut aus die durchblutung ist
gut die frucht wassermenge ist auch gut
vom kind das sieht alles gut aus
es spricht nichts gegen eine normale
geburt kennen wir das so mal ansteuern
das eine normale geburt ja jetzt ist der
kopf unten wir hoffen das bleibt so und
aber sieht so aus weil das schon ein
bisschen tiefer getreten ist es schon
mal ein gutes zeichen und von unserer
seite
wenn es ihnen weiterhin so gut geht und
dem kind spricht nichts gegen eine
normale geburt
[Musik]
obwohl die ärztinnen und ärzte am
zürcher unispital eine natürliche geburt
favorisieren liegt ihrer
kaiserschnittrate bei 40 prozent
aus sicht von leider sultan bayer hat
das gute gründe immer relativieren weil
wir natürlich ein sehr hohes risiko
kollektiv haben wir haben viele
frühgeburten wir haben viele
mehrlingsschwangerschaften dadurch dass
wir das perinatalzentrum ihre engsten
umkreis sind sozusagen haben wir
natürlich ein ganz anderes kollektiv das
kann man nicht mit gesunden jungen
schwangeren vergleichen
die vielleicht vorwiegend in dem
privatspitäler gehen zb wie
beispielsweise in die privatklinikgruppe
hirslanden hier liegt die
kaiserschnittrate weit über dem
landesdurchschnitt
laut eigenen angaben in zürich bei rund
58 prozent vor der kamera wollte dazu
niemand stellung nehmen
hirslanden hat in der geburtshilfe keine
eigenen mediziner arbeitet nur mit
belegärzten die ihre patientinnen
mitbringen
im internet wirbt die klinikkette vor
allem für zahlungskräftige
privatversicherte
die 16 spitäler in der schweiz gehören
zum unternehmen medi klinik
international
es ist an der börse kotiert und hat
seinen hauptsitz in südafrika die
werbung verspricht gebären mit
wellnesscharakter
weltweit sind privat patientinnen die
einen kaiserschnitt erhalten für
kliniken äußerst lukrativ in der schweiz
können sie mit bis zu 15.000 franken
abgerechnet werden natürliche geburten
von einfach versicherten hingegen nur
mit 3000 obwohl die ärztinnen und ärzte
oft länger beanspruchen als seine kurze
op doch der finanzielle vorteil ist nur
ein motiv für die weltweit steigenden
kaiserschnittraten
es ist die planbarkeit der operation
viele geburten in kurzer zeit so wird
die sectio zum geschäftsmodell wie in
der privaten klinikkette perinatale in
einem modernen business park von rio de
janeiro in fünf häusern kommen hier
jeden monat um die 5000 kinder zur welt
85 prozent von ihnen per kaiserschnitt
jeden nachmittag füllt sich der
warteraum mit schwangeren
perry natal ist wie hirslanden eine
billig klinik in der die ärzte einen
operationssaal mieten sie arbeiten dort
wenn sie ihre praxen in der stadt
geschlossen haben
so auch die ärztin von barbara griesbach
natürliche geburten betreut sie fasten
ist die logistik einer normalen geburt
also die wien können zum beispiel
frühmorgens einsetzen während man
vielleicht in einen ganz anderen
krankenhaus ist da muss man durch die
ganze stadt um die geburt durchzuführen
die zeit die man bei der patienten
bleibt während der wien das können 12 18
24 stunden seien an solch einem tag
bleibt die ganze andere aber gegen das
alles macht es für den arzt zu
unangenehm und für patientinnen wie
barbara kostspielig denn ihre
versicherung übernimmt diese
zusatzkosten nicht
am späten nachmittag beginnt für viele
mediziner aus rio die zweite schicht
operiert wird den fünf operationssälen
gleichzeitig nicht nur brasilianischen
ärzten auch fotografen bietet der
kaiserschnitt einen attraktiven
zusatzverdienst denn viele eltern lassen
die geburt aufzeichnen
das standardpaket mit 70 fotos und zehn
minuten film kostet 250 franken
[Musik]
während sich in einem operationssaal ein
stolzer vater noch mit seinem nachwuchs
präsentiert wartet barbara gries bahn im
nebenraum bereits auf ihren
kaiserschnitt mittlerweile ist es 23 uhr
endlich ist barbara dran
seit zehn stunden ist die studentin und
schon in der klinik unter höchster
anspannung nach einer schwangerschaft
ohne komplikationen
[Musik]
einen geplanten kaiserschnitt setzen
mediziner meist zwei wochen vor dem
eigentlichen geburtstermin an
doch nicht immer ist die lunge des
kindes dann schon vollständig ausgereift
[Musik]
es ist ein junge alles ist in ordnung
sie darf ihr kind sehen doch gerade
einmal so lange dass der vater fotos
machen kann
alles geht schnell die gemietet derzeit
im op ist kostbar
[Musik]
schon ist für barbara der erste moment
mit ihrem kind erinnerung
[Musik]
eine schwester versucht das neugeborene
zu beruhigen
es ist bald mitternacht und alle sind
mit ihren kräften am ende
der frischgebackene vater darf den rest
der nabelschnur abtrennen
einen namen für ihren sohn hat das paar
auch schon
er wird roberto heißen genau wie der
vater
nur noch die engsten familienmitglieder
haben ausgab erleichtert aber total
erschöpft von langen warten begrüßen sie
das neue familienmitglied
solange eine sektion mehr finanzielle
anreize bietet als eine natürliche
geburt wird die kaiserschnittrate in
brasilien und anderen ländern
wahrscheinlich weiterhin steigen
weltweit ist so beobachten eine hohe
anzahl an privat- und beleg kliniken
hebt die statistische häufigkeit der
schnittentbindung
[Musik]
nirgendwo auf der welt haben sich die
kaiserschnittraten rasanter entwickelt
als in china
[Musik]
innerhalb von nur 20 jahren hat sich die
kaiserschnittrate in china nahezu
verzehnfacht von sechs auf über 50
prozent
in manchen provinzen liegt sie schon bei
80 prozent
parallel zum wirtschaftswachstum des
landes schnellte der planbare
wunschkaiserschnitt unter schwangeren in
die höhe
[Musik]
im reich der mitte kommen jährlich 18
millionen babys zur welt das sind 9
millionen kaiserschnitte kliniken stehen
damit auch vor logistischen problemen
der bedarf an krankenhausbetten op
personal und bluttransfusionen ist in
den letzten jahren rapide gestiegen
[Musik]
erst kürzlich hat die regierung die
ein-kind-politik aufgehoben
eine entscheidung die auch den umgang
mit dem kaiserschnitt in ein völlig
neues licht rückt ein kaiserschnitt
birgt bei einer zweiten schwangerschaft
höhere risiken für die mutter in der
shanghaier frauenklinik kommen jährlich
25.000 babys zur welt chinesische ärzte
akzeptieren den wunsch kaiserschnitt
ohne große nachfrage in seiner
sprechstunde wird der klinikdirektor
allerdings häufig mit einem besonderen
anliegen konfrontiert
sie möchten dass ihr kind an einem
sogenannten glückstag zur welt kommt zum
beispiel an einem 18 18 oder 28 eines
monats
die leute glauben dass es erfolg bringt
an diesen daten geboren zu werden
ein weiterer grund kann auch einen
speziellen tag betreffen wenn das
geburtsdatum für ende august oder anfang
september berechnet wurde
dann wollen sie lieber noch den august
denn alle kinder die vor dem ersten
september geboren werden können ein jahr
früher zur schule gehen
auch in der 2000 kilometer entfernten
provinz sichuan ist der aberglaube weit
verbreitet sondern hat vor kurzem
geheiratet und einen sohn bekommen nun
wohnt sie wie in china üblich mit ihrem
mann bei den schwiegereltern die sich
hauptsächlich um das kind kümmern
die oma hat ihren enkel warm eingepackt
es ist winter in sichuan und die wohnung
ohne heizung nicht erst seit der kleine
handliche auf der welt ist dreht sich
alles um ihn schon vor seiner geburt
machte sich die 22-jährige mutter viele
gedanken
sie wollte nichts dem zufall überlassen
als ich erfahren habe dass ich schwanger
war habe ich überlegt an welchem tag
mein kind geboren werden soll
ich habe in büchern und im internet
nachgeschaut und versucht
herauszubekommen welcher tag ein
glückstag sein könnte am ende habe ich
den siebten ausgewählt der siebte juli
ist in china der valentinstag auch in
chinesischen mondkalender ist das ein
guter tag
dann habe ich noch im freundeskreis
nachgefragt und sie haben es mir
bestätigt so wurde es der siebte siebter
zu unserer zeit haben alle ihre kinder
auf natürliche weise bekommen als die 51
jährige schwanger war galt der
kaiserschnitt noch als notoperation den
ärzte möglichst vermieden
ich glaube eine natürliche geburt ist
besser danach erholt man sich schneller
doch der tief verwurzelte aberglaube
beeinflusst nach wie vor auch junge
chinesinnen eine acht dem geburtsdatum
etwas steht für glück die neuen für
ewigkeit die vier gilt es zu vermeiden
die schriftzeichen ist doppeldeutig es
bedeutet auch tot als sie schwanger war
habe ich gehört dass die meisten meiner
freundinnen und kolleginnen einen
kaiserschnitt hatten und eine die ihr
kind normal bekommen hat hat mir erzählt
dass es sehr schmerzhaft war und dass
sie einen damm schnitt gemacht haben
da dachte ich wenn das sowieso eines so
schmerzhaft ist kann ich mich auch
gleich operieren lassen und muss die wii
nicht aushalten
man hat ja nur schmerzen wenn die
narkose nachlässt jeder hat mir erzählt
dass ein kaiserschnitt besser ist
deshalb habe ich mich am ende auch dafür
entschieden
tino costa
viele junge chinesen haben große angst
vor der geburt denn es kursieren
schauergeschichten rund um das ereignis
sie fürchten vor allem dass hier becken
nicht für den kopf eines kindes
ausgestattet ist aufklärung darüber gibt
es in china wenig und auch keine
beratungsstellen an die sich die
schwangeren mit ihrem problem wenden
könnten
[Musik]
in der gesellschaft wird das thema
geburts angst oft nicht ernst genommen
[Musik]
frauen von heute sie zu verwöhnt sie
wollen überhaupt keine schmerzen mehr
aushalten auch nicht bei der geburt
[Musik]
dennoch die familie kam gemeinsam für
die kosten des kaiserschnitts auf 10.000
yuan etwa 1400 franken hat sie aus
eigener tasche gezahlt für ein gutes
krankenhaus
auch der wunschtermin kostet extra
innerhalb von nur 20 jahren hat china
mit seiner geburten tradition gebrochen
ist der start ins leben vom wunsch
kaiserschnitt bestimmt bei einer zweiten
schwangerschaft würde für die junge
chinesin wohl auch wieder nur ein
kaiserschnitt in frage kommen
[Musik]
in brasilien erholt sich barbara graes
bahn von der operation
ihre ärztin ist gekommen um sich zu
verabschieden
bereits nach einem tag werden
patientinnen hier entlassen
die geburt ist barbara daher noch sehr
präsent
es war doch ein bisschen anders
ich dachte ich hätte weniger schmerzen
ich dachte auch die narkose würde
schneller gehen
aber wenn ich ihn hier sehe dann ist
alles okay
[Musik]
sollte die 22 jährige noch einmal
schwanger werden wird sie wieder kommen
die chancen ein zweites kind auf
natürlichem wege zu bekommen stehen
nicht gut
in brasilien gilt einmal kaiserschnitt
immer kaiserschnitt auch weil junge
ärzte hier in erster linie lernen mit
dem skalpell umzugehen entsprechend ihre
ratschläge an die patientinnen es will
hat jedes recht auf eine natürliche
geburt
ich selbst habe mich bei meinem kind
nicht dafür entschieden
ich informiere meine patientinnen
natürlich über pro und contra aber ich
glaube wirklich dass sich besser alle
für den kaiserschnitt entscheiden
sollten so sehe ich das
in frankreich sehen dass viele mediziner
ganz anders nur 21 prozent aller kinder
kommen hier per kaiserschnitt zur welt
dabei heben privatkliniken noch den
durchschnitt
in der pariser uniklinik robert übrig
greifen die ärzte sogar nur bei 17
prozent der schwangeren zum skalpell
obwohl sie viele komplizierte geburten
betreuen
professor jean francois uri chef der
geburtsabteilung hat jahrzehntelange
erfahrung insbesondere bei relativen
indikationen bei denen ein kaiserschnitt
nicht zwingend nötig ist unterstützt er
die natürliche geburt so es sieht ganz
so aus als würde alles gut verlaufen
wir werden sie während der geburt gut
überwachen und alles dafür tun damit
alles ganz normal verläuft und sie ihr
kind auf natürlichem wege bekommen
können
für uns ist ein vorheriger
kaiserschnitts kein zwingender grund
wieder einen kaiserschnitt zu machen
eine steißlage ebenfalls nicht und auch
zwillinge müssen nicht zwangsläufig per
kaiserschnitt entbunden werden
komplikationen schauen wir uns genau an
natürlich wollen wir weder die frauen
noch die kinder in gefahr bringen
aber wir folgen nach wie vor den
klassischen empfehlungen der
geburtshilfe doch was früher als zeit
der guten hoffnung galt weicht heute
immer mehr den blick für risiken
dabei rücken seit einiger zeit für
ärztinnen und ärzte auch zunehmend
andere aspekte in den fokus es ist
wesentlich einfacher um 10 uhr morgens
einen kaiserschnitt zu machen als nachts
um 3 uhr herbei zu eilen
das ist ja viel bequemer wenn irgendwas
nicht glatt läuft sofort einen
kaiserschnitt zu machen ist ja klar
bei einem vorangegangenen kaiserschnitts
einer steißlage oder zwillingen leuten
dann die alarmglocken meine güte was
passiert wenn etwas schief geht werden
sie mich verklagen
das ist fürchterlich so läuft es in den
usa sie denken so wenn etwas schief
läuft werde ich angeklagt deshalb lese
ich das problem lieber gleich so
entsteht dann ein völlig falsches
verhalten
es gibt diesen spruch es wurde noch nie
jemand wegen eines kaiserschnitts
verurteilt den er zu viel gemacht wird
aber wohl wegen einer vaginalen geburt
die möglicherweise durch einen
kaiserschnitt ein anderes ergebnis
ergeben hätte und das macht natürlich
angst und hat dazu geführt allerdings
dass mittlerweile die schadenssummen in
der geburtshilfe die mit abstand
höchsten sind die in deutschland
verzeichnet werden und so gibt es
mittlerweile fast keine versicherung in
deutschland die geburtshelfer versichert
professor frank louwen chef der
geburtsabteilung im uniklinikum
frankfurt setzt sich in deutschland
daher für neue leitlinien in der
geburtshilfe ein die auch die natürliche
geburt unterstützen sollen
mit der entscheidung dass wir aus
eigenen sicherheits grünen mehr
kaiserschnitte machen geht natürlich das
wissen verloren wo entstehen risiken bei
einer normalen geburt und wie gehen wir
damit um
geburtshelfer die aus angst vor klagen
lieber zum skalpell greifen die
ökonomisierung der medizin und einer
gesellschaft die immer mehr sicherheit
fordert ist die natürliche geburt schon
bald eine ausnahme genau das befürchten
hebammen auch sie stehen schon lange
unter druck können die hohen
versicherungsprämien oft nicht mehr
zahlen
immer wieder auch ein thema an der
katholischen hochschule für hebammen
wissenschaften in köln
für mich ist die diskussion im
zusammenhang mit dem kaiserschnitt das
keiner nach der frau schaut die frau
kommt in eine situation der existenziell
bedeutsamen situation mit der geburt und
versucht dinge wie ihre angst durch
vorwegnahmen zu überleben also sie macht
sich gedanken wie wir das bei mir darf
sein werde ich nackt sein und kommt in
eine sehr verängstigte situation und die
unsere studien sagen zeigen uns dass
viele frauen angst haben vor autonomie
verlust und in dem zusammenhang der
autonomie versucht versucht man zu
klären
es wäre die sechste jetzt eine
möglichkeit der lösung letztendlich
haben wir aber das problem die frau in
ihrem angewiesen sein also in ihrer
bedürftigkeit in ihrer brüchigkeit zu
verstehen weltweit ist zu beobachten
dort wo die zahl der hebammen sinkt
steigt die kaiserschnittrate die
forderung persönliche zuwendung muss
wieder einen höheren stellenwert in der
geburtshilfe bekommen das ist etwas wo
ich sagen da müssen wir hinschauen was
bedeutet das also auch für diese
gesellschaft was bedeutet das für die
eigene identität wenn die frau sich als
produkt versteht wenn die frau die
geburt ihres kindes als produkt versteht
sonja bolz hat es geschafft ihr sohn ist
ganz natürlich zur welt gekommen wir
sind total glücklich
wenn es jedoch als regent gehabt das ist
unser wunsch viel erreicht dass es
natürlich im boot gehabt und das klappt
hat und das ist jetzt ganz einfach sie
will anfang in der anfangsphase für die
konstruktion sind herzen von baby und
gesundheit
das ist ein sexy videos geburt wo es auf
dem bio im ersten song sing und dem
setzte team von dem universitätsspital
immer und hat das bereits werkseitig
auch wenn es weiterhin so sinkt dann
müsste ein kaiserschnitt in china
trotz einiger schwierigkeiten erlebte
michael brod die geburt seines zweiten
kindes relativ entspannt ich hasse dich
nicht von mir sehr geschätzte haus
gefühllos dass das turnier vor mahnungen
mit einem schmerzen sehr gut umgegangen
ist
was die kauf dass das hat nicht in einer
fabrik tourentipps fahr stolz gemacht
das ist und dort mit dem auto kurz kgv
selbst sexistischen die gut serviere
körper kennt wenn ich etwas normal
geburt ist es schon so dass dass ich
mich in meine dritte fall wieder wird
für ihre normal- gebot entscheiden
es kommen nach der geburt hat ich habe
es meiner meinung nach viel schöner
es sind stolz dass man das geschafft hat
und nicht so viel glückshormon viel mehr
als nach einem kaiserschnitt
wobei ich sagen muss es ist wenn man es
nicht anders kommt und wenn man sich das
auch gar nicht vorstellen wie laut
wünscht sich rang kaiserschnitt gute
möglichkeit also der unterschiedlichen
hat viel weniger schmerzen während der
geburt und im nachgang hat man mehr
schmerze wenn man der kaiserschnitt
machen dass es gott länger zum wii fit
werden
nach dem angebot eines frosches
schnellgang doch manchmal klappt es aus
den verschiedensten gründen nicht mit
der natürlichen geburt
schwangere können dann in der berliner
charité etwas ganz neues ausprobieren
ärzte haben hier die methode eines
australischen arztes aufgegriffen eltern
bei der schnittentbindung zu schauen zu
lassen
kaiser geburt ist der begriff den
professor wolfgang henrich dafür geprägt
hat das ist härter als ein diamant und
die antwort ist die tradition und
medizinische traditionen und abläufe
sind oftmals sehr verhärtet
und ich gebe zu dass ich selber über 23
jahre den kaiserschnitten der
herkömmlichen art und weise durchgeführt
habe das war auch nicht schlecht aber
dieser impuls gegeben hat es weniger als
eine operation darzustellen sondern mehr
als ein geburtserlebnis hat mich
überzeugt
die operation beginnt wie ein
herkömmlicher kaiserschnitt doch sobald
der rat den kopf des kindes sieht wird
das tuch gesenkt dass die schwangere vom
geschehen abgeschirmt hat
vor den augen der eltern sieht der arzt
das kind aus dem bauch
das beschreibt was steckt drin
wir machen diese methode auch bei frauen
die den normalen geburtstags versuchen
die wegen einem auffälligen schick eg
oder wegen eines gebots stillstandes
eben umsteigen müssen auf die sektion
und eine spielform ganz besonders für
diese frauen geeignet und sie ist ein
trost dass sie dann doch die endstücke
sozusagen den letzten die letzten
minuten vor der geburt dann auch richtig
mit sehen können daran teilnehmen und
letztendlich dann doch noch ein
gesteigertes geburtserlebnis haben
das neugeborene kommt sofort zur mutter
und bleibt so lange wie möglich dort in
der ersten stunde nach der geburt sind
seine sinne hellwach es ist ein
besonders aufnahmefähig für gerüche und
geräusche die stimmen von mutter und
vater
ergriffen vom augenblick nehmen die
eltern den verlauf der weiteren
operation gar nicht mehr wahr
die kaiser geburt ein erlebnis nah an
der natürlichen entbindung
doch ob kaiserschnitt oder kaiser geburt
es bleibt eine operation
diese diskussion ist eine kaiser geburt
sinnvoll ja oder nein
also die kaiser geburt per se als also
abzulehnen würde ich sagen ist wird
schwer fallen
und das tue ich auch nicht aber die
frage ist was passiert hier also man
bindet doch eine form von
zwischenmenschlichkeit in technik
nämlich dass den kaiserschnitt ein
und ich würde es mir genau andersrum
wünschen nämlich eine form von
zwischenmenschlichkeit die da ist und
wenn die technik erforderlich ist binden
wir die technik metall und das wird bei
der kaiser geburt leider umgedreht und
das sind dinge die ich bemängeln für
schwangere denen nichts als die sektion
bleibt scheint die kaiser geburt eine
echte alternative
[Applaus]
[Musik]
es war wie es war richtig gut und sie
hat ja beim ersten kaiserschnitt hatte
sie das nicht also da würde das einfach
sagt man hat das baby noch mal kurz an
die waage gehalten und weg das ist jetzt
18 jahre her
dann sieht man halt jetzt hier wie weit
die technik schon und deshalb schon wenn
man das dann als eltern seien miterleben
kann es ist ja wieder echte geburt
gewesen jetzt sei es kein unterschied
außer dass es woanders herausgekommen
ist das war kurz
so
der kaiserschnitt als geburt der zukunft
drückt immer näher
ein großer teil der menschheit kommt
heute so bereits zur welt ohne wären
ohne den natürlichen prozess der
hormonausschüttung damit greift die
medizin tief in die evolution des
menschen ein
ungeachtet einer möglichen folgen
die hohen kaiserschnittraten sieht ein
spiegel der gesellschaft
sie stellen aber auch das
selbstverständnis eines jeden
geburtshelfer auf den prüfstand
wenn man seine arbeit liebt und die
geburtshilfe gelernt hat dann muss man
auch versuchen sie anzuwenden
jedenfalls verteidigen sie das heißt
nicht dass wir gegen kaiserschnitte sind
das heißt wir sind dafür wenn sie gute
indikationen haben aber wir müssen
vielmehr wieder lernen frauen zu helfen
auch ganz normal ihre kinder zu kriegen
doch nur wenn weder finanzielle
interessen noch ängste den start ins
leben bestimmen und frauen auf erfahrene
ärzte und hebammen bauen können wird die
kaiserschnittrate senken
was hat mich verzichtet macht doch das
klappt mit dem internet etliche geboten
das hat sich dann im märz öffnet ihm im
kopf und der wunsch wieder erwachte mir
dass ich das welt probieren und ich bin
sicher dass es klappt und während im
geburtsverlauf gespürt
auch wenn die natürliche geburt nicht
immer komplikationslos verläuft der
kaiserschnitt birgt möglicherweise
ebenfalls risiken und die erforschung
der langzeitfolgen für das kind hat
gerade erst begonnen
[Musik]